Russia's war against Ukraine has led to
new efforts to overthrow the rule of
Vladimir Putin a drone attack on the
Kremlin last month was one of a growing
number of attacks inside Russia and one
of the anti-putin groups claiming to
take part is the so-called freedom of
Russia Legion that's the name formed
last year by Russians cooperating with
Ukrainian forces to fight what they call
Putin's armed gang Holly Williams has a
closer look
16 months after Vladimir Putin launched
his invasion of Ukraine now it's Russia
that's coming under attack
the freedom freed of Russia Legion made
up of Russian defectors and based inside
Ukraine has launched incursions into
Southern Russia in recent weeks sending
local residents fleeing
how does this work are your guys going
to fight their way to Moscow and seize
control of the Kremlin yes
says he's the freedom of Russia legion's
political representative he's a former
member of the Russian Duma or Parliament
who became an enemy of Vladimir Putin
and now lives in Exile do you think that
Vladimir Putin's regime is going to
collapse anytime soon no I think it's
coming this year this year this year why
do you think that
so we see the events how they are
evolving in Russia so I think that his
region would collapse many others
believe
dly
has an approval rating of around 80
percent but it's true that his military
has suffered a string of humiliating
failures in Ukraine with more than 200
000 Russian casualties according to the
U.S and the freedom of Russia Legion is
so worrying Moscow has declared it a
terrorist organization in Ukraine in
April we met two of its young Fighters
determined to stop Putin many people
back in Russia would say that your
traitors what would you say to them
it's our country that betrayed us he
told us unleashing this war without
asking anybody
last month the terror of War arrived in
Central Moscow drone attacks on
residential streets in the Russian
Capital now the war has come back to
Russia the Drone attacks the shellings
of Border regions that definitely starts
you know making people think about
something is going wrong
Constantine is a Russian political
commentator who's critical of Putin and
fled his country last year fearing he'd
be arrested he also believes Russia's
leader has been critically weakened by a
war that isn't going to plan
he is in power for as long as
he's confident and he shows that he is
strong so that's one of the reasons that
I say this is the beginning of the end
for him
Ukraine has denied any involvement in
those attacks within Russia now we
should tell you that the freedom of
Russia Legion has cooperated with
another armed Russian group that
reportedly has links to neo-nazis
ilyoponomario have Justified that by
saying they're his allies because they
want to defeat Vladimir Putin the big
question is whether these attacks really
pose a threat to Putin I don't have a
clear-cut answer for that but they do
show that some Russians are willing to
risk everything to try to get rid of him
Gail
seems so thank you very much Holly
Williams reporting from London